-Performing the title track
to her new album,
"Falling or Flying"
and "Little Things,"
please welcome Jorja Smith!
♪♪
-♪ This ain't what
your mother told you ♪
♪ It's night and day ♪
♪ If you're waitin' for
a sign to come and hold me ♪
♪ Well, you might as well
spend all your night guessin'♪
♪♪
♪ If this ain't
what your mother told you ♪
♪ Forget what she said ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ If you want this to be real ♪
♪ Then show me you want me ♪
♪ Don't play it safe with me ♪
♪ Oh no, no ♪
♪ Won't work if I'm numb ♪
♪ Won't stop if I love ♪
♪ Who hurts if you don't? ♪
♪ Don't fall
from these heights ♪
♪ Won't stop if you won't ♪
♪ Won't learn if you don't ♪
♪ Who else could get me ♪
♪ To fall from these heights? ♪
♪ I don't know where you are ♪
♪ But I don't wanna go to sleep,
babe ♪
♪ I know you care, but please ♪
♪ Don't take it easy on me,
babe ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh, hey ♪
♪ I could be fallin' or flyin' ♪
♪ I wouldn't
know the difference ♪
♪♪
♪ I don't know where you are ♪
♪ But I don't wanna go to sleep,
babe ♪
♪ I know you care, but please ♪
♪ Don't take it easy on me,
babe ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh, hey ♪
♪ I could be fallin' or flyin' ♪
♪ I wouldn't
know the difference ♪
♪♪
-♪ I didn't know that
you'd be here tonight ♪
♪ Saw you again,
think this must be a sign ♪
♪ Nothing was said, it was
all in your eyes, oh ♪
♪ Can I get close,
even for just one time? ♪
♪ It's the little things
that get me high ♪
♪ Won't you come with me
and spend the night? ♪
♪ Just a little thing
for you and I ♪
♪ And if it's meant to be,
then that's alright ♪
♪ It's the little things
that get me high ♪
♪ Won't you come with me
and spend the night? ♪
♪ Just a little thing
for you and I ♪
♪ And if it's meant to be ♪
♪ Then that's alright ♪
♪ It's the little things ♪
♪ That get me high,
keep me going ♪
♪ Just a little bit of
you and I, nobody knows it ♪
♪ Just a little bit
for you and I ♪
♪ Just a little bit of
you and I, nobody knows it ♪
♪ It's the little things that
get me high and keep me going ♪
♪ Just a little bit of
you and I, nobody knows it ♪
♪ Just a little thing
for you and I ♪
♪ Just a little bit of
you and I, nobody knows it ♪
-What time is it?
When the party stops.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]